It reminds me of other...
Other expressions, other words.
Hello, this is Steve Kaufman
and I want to talk about,
of course, language learning
but above all about the
importance of forgetting...
when learning words
and languages.
If you like my videos,
please subscribe.
Click on the bell
to get notifications.
And if you’re following me
through a Podcast service
Please leave a comment.
I really appreciate it.
Good.
I often hear people saying
"I have a bad memory"
"I have difficulty in
learning languages"
"I don't have the talent
to learn languages"
And I always say that
learning languages
is a question of
acquiring habits
and it is not a
question of talent...
There may be
talent differences
but that's not the
most important thing
but it is about wanting to
get exposed to the language
and not worrying too much
about things we forget.
And that indeed, forgetting is a
very important part of learning
and because...
Inevitably, we will forget
everything we learn,
we will forget it
and we will relearn it and
then, again, forget it.
And there is researches that
were made in California
A professor, Robert Bjork,
who demonstrates that...
Our memory is
not only in things
that we can remember, that
we can fetch in a context
when we are talking,
when we read something.
But memory also consists
in what he calls the "Reserve"
that is to say things that we’ve knew
or that we saw and that we heared
and who entered our memory
but that we are not
able to find or look for.
"to retrieve them"
as we say in English.
But these are still things
which are part of our memory.
And in language learning,
these are the things we forget.
And often, as Proust
said, things that we...
Maybe sometimes
unpleasant things or things…
where there is no effort
purposely to remember them.
These are the things we're going
to remember at some point.
And even me,
I had this experience
because I am trying
to prepare a speech
that I will give to
lawyers going to Ukraine.
And I will give
this presentation
on language learning and it is
actually in Ukrainian and English.
So I decided to refresh my
Ukrainian language a little
and so I studied the mini stories
we have at LingQ and by doing so...
I saw that even by relearning fairly
common high frequency words
it reminds me of other
expressions and other words.
So it stimulated me to dig
in what was in memory
let's say directly there,
words that I was relearning.
There are other words
that I wasn’t reading
that I wasn't hearing, that I wasn't
listening to and who reappeared
So, that is to say,
the reserve that we create
every time we listen and read
even if we forget the word,
we forget the expression.
These are things that
are saved in our memory
and it is by forgetting the words and the
expressions, that we increase the reserve.
And it's from these
words there, possibly
that we’ll finally create an important
vocabulary that will allow us
to have interesting
conversations with people
understand books, etc.
and in the LingQ
system in particular.
I realized that since the first
time we encounter a word in LingQ
it is underlined in blue and
then we convert it to LingQ.
So it gets a yellow color,
but all the words in yellow...
These are words that
we can't remember.
Because the words we
understand in any context.
These are known words.
So if I look at my stats
in different languages
that I studied on LingQ
Well...
For example Ukrainian,
I know about 60,000 words
and actually fewer yellow
words, that is to say words
which are part of my reserve
because it's a language...
I listened to and read a lot and
even studying Russian or Czech
helped me a lot to recognize
words when studying Ukrainian.
On the other hand, if I look at my
statistics in Arabic or Persian.
Well, there are three times
more words in my reserve
that is to say words that
I have met, that I have read
that I looked for
and then I forgot.
It's three times more
than the words that I knew
that I can recognize
in a context.
In the case of Arabic, I have about
60,000 or even more words
that I went looking for the
meaning in the dictionary.
I put them in my database.
It's part of my reserve
but I can't recognize only 20,000
of these words, so just a third.
The case of Persian is similar.
I have about 30,000
words that I’ve saved
which are in my database and
are therefore part of my reserve.
But I only have
12,000 known words
that is to say that each time
I see them, I understand them
and that's totally
fine, that's normal.
And finally, if I keep going
in the end, I would have
more words that I can use.
But the important thing here is
that one shouldn’t demand too much
that we can immediately recall
words that we have studied.
We must accept forgetting,
“creative forgetting”
The fact that all these
listening and reading activities
and seeing words, listening
to words and expressions
grow our, let's say...
facilitate our language habits
with this new language.
And make also
our reserve grow.
So even if we have the
impression of not progressing
because we are no longer
in this beginners course
where there are so many frequent
words that are learned fairly quickly.
Now we're in this
called “Plateau”.
So there, you have to realize
that by reading and listening
by increasing our reserve,
we create the conditions.
So, I mean, by forgetting
words, we create the conditions
that will allow us to reach a
level, let’s say, in the language
the desired level of ability
to speak the language fluently.
Well, that's what I wanted
to say about this subject.
and I’ll leave some videos I have
done about this memory subject.
Concerning languages learning.
Thanks! Goodbye.